[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
May 18th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
the share of marriages with women making
more money has grown significantly over
the past 50 years wsj personal finance
reporter Julia Carpenter joins us to
discuss how it's affecting marriages so
Julia what sparked this trend of women
making the same or more than men in
their marriage we've seen this slow
growth women are attending college more
women are gaining Advanced degrees and
as a result they're better positioned to
land these higher paying jobs in your
reporting you cite research showing that
opposite sex married couples in the late
1960s and 70s were 70 percent more
likely to divorce when wives earn the
same or slightly more than their
husbands compared with couples where the
husband earned more how has that changed
we've seen a pretty dramatic reversal of
that Trend so the 80s we saw the the
number drop slightly and then for
Couples married in the 90s the divorce
rate for those with female Breadwinners
was four percent higher than male
Breadwinners so a pretty significant
drop why was the divorce rate in that
income scenario so much higher so
researchers point to a couple different
things they're social factors of course
you know greater acceptance of women in
the workplace greater advancement of
women in the workplace and husbands
feeling less threatened by women earning
more but there's also economic factors
you know it used to be that single
family could subsist off of one
Breadwinner it was ideal that one person
would work and one person would stay at
home now both Partners really have to be
maximizing their income potential in
order for these families to reach these
Milestones that were once much more
easily accessible yeah it's never been
cheap to live but how have Rising
household expenses played a role here
it's
significant for parents I think that's
where most people can see their
household balance sheets change most
dramatically child care costs really
vary depending on where you live but as
of the most recent numbers daycare can
cost anywhere from eight thousand
dollars a year to nearly twenty thousand
dollars a year so that's a significant
cost for many parents you mentioned a
moment ago that men have felt threatened
by their wives making more than them
what's the story behind that you know
it's a pretty traditional gender role
story we see that men feel threatened if
they are not the Sole Provider they feel
that that is somehow a statement about
their role in the marriage their
masculinity their ability to provide but
I was speaking with one couple and they
both work in the library world she earns
more than him she's a tribal archivist
and she said that she was a little
nervous actually to tell him when she
first exceeded him in salary because we
had had all this messaging about how men
feel in these relationships she didn't
want to challenge the great relationship
they had and what he said I thought was
so telling and and really sort of
indicative of how many men feel now he
said more money for her is more money
for us more money for me is more money
for us so he saw instead is a statement
about himself as a partner more of a
celebration for their household now
looking at women specifically they've
held prestigious highly paid positions
for decades but what has changed for
them in particular over time in terms of
marriage when you look at research that
examines women in the c-suite history
we've seen that those women are actually
likelier to be divorced when they reach
the upper echelons of their profession
something has happened to their
marriages along the way either them
earning more than their husband led to
divorce or the power imbalance in their
relationship created some sort of
acrimony but that's changing now we're
seeing now that as women Advance they're
likelier to stay married when you spoke
to couples in this income situation do
they talk about any kind of an
adjustment or learning curve that help
them understand and come to the feeling
that yeah this could actually work I
think younger couples they have more
models to point to and that was
something that came up frequently in my
interviews for Couples married in the
2000s or later the models of the 60s and
70s that we had discussed previously
with those High divorce rates those are
much more in the past for these younger
couples and I actually spoke with one
couple they're engaged to be married and
they each had been the soul Breadwinner
the primary Breadwinner in their
previous marriages it's a couple named
Sally and Luis and when I spoke with
Louise about this he said that he really
welcomed this change that in his first
marriage he had felt the pressure he had
felt the burden of being the soul
Breadwinner and now that his fiance
makes nearly triple what he makes he
welcomes it he sees the Financial
Freedom it can afford their household
and he says that together they can sort
of think about what this money can do
for them as they plan for the future so
as women take on a more prominent role
in the workplace what is this done to
alleviate the gender pay Gap so this is
the complication here women still make
less than men according to the most
recent data from Pew women make 82
percent of what their male counterparts
make so we're seeing a slight change in
that and if you look at the research
especially looking at younger couples a
Pew also has some research showing that
Millennial women at the very beginning
of their careers sometimes out earn
their male peers so there's something
that happens later in women's careers
either again the Parenthood conversation
you know how they're going to afford
child care if someone needs to stay home
if someone's going to drop out of the
workforce temporarily that disrupts
women's earning power over time we also
know that women are frequently and lower
paying Industries than men there are
certain positions in certain industries
that are seen as women's Industries and
those pay less so this isn't a story
unfortunately that shows that more
egalitarian marriages create more
egalitarian workplaces and more
egalitarian earnings for women but we
are seeing this slowly change over time
that's Wall Street Journal personal
financial reporter Julia Carpenter and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]